[Music]
he was brilliant and beloved remembering
and celebrating Robbie Robertson one of
Canada's most influential musicians
[Music]
also on this Wednesday night Paradise in
Peril
the Ferocious Flames ripping through
Maui Island and the Desperate Measures
some people are taking to escape Target
of disinformation why the Chinese
government is suspected of circulating
lies again about a conservative MP
omicron's cousin is spreading what's
known about eg.5
and this is them trying it I have my
lucky charm nail polish on the struggle
to get Taylor Swift tickets
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser good
evening to you thanks for joining us we
begin with breaking news out of the
music world a member of Canadian Rock
royalty Robbie Robertson has died at the
age of 80. the toronto-born
singer-songwriter was lead guitarist for
the band and was known for classic songs
like the weight and The Night They Drove
Old Dixie Down he was inducted into the
Canadian songwriters Hall of Fame and he
also received the Order of Canada in
2011. Mike jolay on one of this
country's greatest musicians
it's hard to take a single Snapshot from
Robbie Robertson's career if there was
one sure it would be from The Last Waltz
the band's epic Martin Scorsese directed
farewell concert
[Music]
but he didn't start out there there were
the years in the Hawks Ronnie Hawkins
backup band before Bob Dylan poached
them
to help lead his electric Revolution
away from folk well it taught me to Duck
because people were booing and throwing
stuff at us but before all that he was a
musical prodigy growing up in Toronto
and while he embraced his mother's
Mohawk Heritage later in his solo career
never been before
there was a stigma to being indigenous
in the 1950s and 60s advice that I got
when I was very young was be proud that
you're an Indian but be careful who you
tell
time for Robertson and the other Hawks
to figure out their identity the band
was really without peer they were
probably the best ever backing band
anybody had ever hired and then they
went on to do their own their own thing
and they were great at doing that too it
wasn't until Dylan was sidelined by a
motorcycle accident in 1966 that they
set out on their own as a result the
bans 80 Canadian dudes led by a guy from
Six Nations uh turned into one of the
most important and most influential
bands of the late 1960s and early 1970s
I've said before this wasn't a group
that had a cute singer with his shirt
off and a guitar player and some other
guys playing behind them
this was a group that everybody did
something so extraordinary that we were
all impressed with one another Robertson
never said it but he carried the burden
of leading the band along the way
becoming one of the greatest Canadian
songwriters of his era
[Music]
Global News Toronto he just heard Mike
reference Robbie Robertson's creative
partnership with Martin Scorsese
Robertson composed numerous film scores
later in his career working with
Scorsese on the Raging Bull that
departed The Wolf of Wall Street the
Irishman and their final collaboration
killers of the flower Moon which comes
out in October the director told
deadline this afternoon that Robbie
Robertson was one of my closest friends
a constant in my life and my work I
could always go to him as a confidant a
collaborator an advisor I tried to be
the same for him there's never enough
time with anyone you love and I loved
Robbie
in lieu of flowers Robertson's family
has asked that anyone wishing to honor
him donate to the Six Nations at the
Grand River in Ontario to support a new
culture center for the community
[Music]
to why now an apocalyptic scene
catastrophic wildfires are tearing
through Maui tonight Flames are raging
with such ferocity and at such an
alarming rate at least six people are
dead and hundreds of structures are
destroyed
Maui is the second largest island in the
state of Hawaii and it's a huge tourist
destination visitors are being asked to
leave immediately in a state of
emergency has been declared the National
Guard's been activated to help get
people to safety Jackson prosco reports
on the deadly disaster
thank you with frightening speed the
fires ripped across Maui tearing through
the heart of the historic tourist town
of Lahaina in just minutes I'd be
surprised if there were no fatalities
because this moved quickly there was no
warning there was no preparation no one
was ready for it it happened so fast
there was nowhere to run some made a
harrowing Escape Through the flames
others jumped into the ocean the U.S
Coast Guard rescued at least a dozen
people from the water I was the last one
off the dock when The Firestorm came
through the Banyan tree and took
everything with it and I just ran out to
the beach and I ran South and I just
helped everybody I could along the way
hundreds of buildings burnt to the
ground this pilot Flew Over the
devastation and told a local TV station
there's almost nothing left there's not
even part of the structures left it's
just they're just gone it's erased it's
just it's like a like an area was bombed
in like a war zone
the explosive wildfires were fueled by
extreme winds from Hurricane Dora far
offshore there was little warning and
little expectation it would be this bad
we never anticipated in this state that
a hurricane which did not make impact on
our Islands will cause this type of
wildfires in this popular year-round
tourist destination 2 000 Travelers are
now stranded at the airport including
this couple from Ottawa our flight was
canceled last night so we're making
arrangements to fly up today other
visitors have spent a long day in
evacuation centers looking for a way
home a lot of people have been
contacting our office trying to get out
as soon as possible some people that we
know are Sheltering in high schools to
stay away and stay safe from the fire so
this is concerning on so many levels the
state of Hawaii is now discouraging all
non-essential travel to the island of
Maui with resources scarce and strain
this is not a safe place to be on
certain parts of Mali we have shelters
that are overrun only after the Flames
are gone can anyone begin to tally the
damage in lives and property lost in a
paradise forever scar
Jackson Brosco Global News
Maui relies heavily on tourism and
Canadians are among the biggest fenders
in the first half of this year there
were more than 1.4 million visitors to
Maui up nearly 6 percent over last year
and they spent a staggering 3.5 billion
dollars that's up nearly 25 percent from
2022.
wildfires have also caused heartache and
destruction here in Canada particularly
in BC now that the province is
earmarking more than 880 thousand
dollars for 19 communities to develop
and upgrade evacuation routes and public
notification plans including emergency
alerts
by the time oil finally flows through
the Trans Mountain pipeline expansion
the pipeline that Ottawa bought there
will be a staggering Bill left to pay
documents obtained by global news reveal
a project is burning through hundreds of
millions of dollars each month as costs
ballooned to more than five times the
original budget Heather York's West
explains why the cost to build TMX is
now far more than what the government
can expect to sell it for
four years since construction on the
Trans Mountain pipeline expansion first
began the pipe is still going into the
ground
the path to this point has been anything
but easy a covid-19 pandemic
and Atmospheric river-fueled flooding
contributing to a cost overrun that
dropped Jaws it's you know really cost
way more than anybody would have dreamed
at the beginning initially expected to
cost 5.4 billion that number ballooned
to 30.9 billion by March of 2023 and
money is still being spent last year the
project was burning through 600 to 900
million a month with 875 million spent
in November alone that's a huge cost
overrun
um something that no engineer no person
in project development could ever say is
reasonable built to Twin a pipeline
that's been in operation for more than
70 years the expansion travels 1147
kilometers from Edmonton to Burnaby
through mountain passes and Incredibly
Urban environments too in this
Chilliwack neighborhood the line passes
through a series of backyards Trans
Mountain says external events which
included the flooding in late 2021 only
accounted for 25 percent of the extra
money spent it was engineering overruns
that represented the Lion's Share of the
added costs I think it's really a fair
to say that this project has been
seriously mismanaged and one of the ways
we can tell that is by looking at the
revolving door of contractors that Trans
Mountain has had on the project since
they started divided into a series of
segments most sections saw the original
contractor in charge of construction
replaced during the course of the
project and in parts of segment 5
between Merit and hope three different
contractors were involved Trans Mountain
says its decision to change contractors
were based on contractor capacity and
performance
Finance with money borrowed from
Canada's big Banks backed by federal
government loan guarantees the crown
Corporation hopes to recover
construction costs once the oil begins
to flow but based on the contracts
signed to ship along the line This
analyst believes those earnings will
never be enough when I do a calculation
I see about 18 billion dollars of that
cost increase is going to have no
Revenue associated with it other
analyzes have calculated the difference
at 16 to 20 billion or more
controversial to some highly anticipated
to others this National piece of
infrastructure has come at an Incredible
cost Heather York's West Global News
Calgary
conservative MP Michael Chong has once
again become involved in what Global
Affairs Canada suspects is a smear
campaign by China as Mackenzie gray
reports it's believed Chong was targeted
because of his consistent calls to
describe the treatment of uyghurs a
genocide
clearly a genocide is taking place in
xinjiang he's been an outspoken critic
of Beijing and for the second time
conservative MP Michael Chong was likely
a target of Chinese disinformation
they're trying to hurt Mr Chung's a
reputation they're trying to damage his
capacity to articulate his use Global
Affairs Canada announcing they detected
false narratives about trong's identity
political stances and Family's Heritage
on the social media platform WeChat
Which is popular with Chinese diaspora
according to the department the
operation took place in early May and
saw a coordinated network of WeChat
accounts featured shared and Amplified a
large volume of false or misleading
narratives about Mr chong chong was
briefed on the operation today which
global Affairs deemed highly probable to
have been ordered by the Chinese
Communist party this is certainly not
surprising to us we've been seeing this
uh for almost four decades Chong and his
family had previously been targeted by
Beijing and the lead up to the 2021
federal election intimidation the MP had
not been told about until it was
reported in the Globe and Mail the
Chinese Diplomat involved in that plot
Yahweh was expelled by Canada in May at
roughly the same time the latest
campaign started against Tron this could
reflect the prc's way of doing business
which is if you don't get with the
program we'll come back another sneaky
way the newest development in China's
continued interference in Canadian
Affairs comes as the liberal government
is under pressure to call a public
inquiry and pass new foreign
interference laws ahead of the next
election we shouldn't fall into the Trap
of inquiry first legislate later there
is no reason they can't move on
legislation now while some sort of
inquiry is going on in parallel while
times ticking on new legislation it's
been dragging on for a public inquiry
two minutes on since the Liberals opened
the door to holding one they still
haven't come to terms with opposition
parties or found someone to lead the
review pharah
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa for us tonight
thanks Mackenzie
big cities seeing a brain drain coming
up how some people are being priced out
of their communities and plotting an
exit strategy
foreign
things for certain the pandemic
radically changed the way we live and
even where we live covid-19 has had a
huge impact on housing markets right
across Canada and it's fueled in Exodus
from our priciest provinces with many
forced to relocate and plant new routes
as Ann gaviola explains affordability
has been a driving force
Alberta Canada in March Alberta rolled
out a new campaign enticing people to
move to the province for better economic
prospects we currently have openings in
sectors right across the province
so it's time to put out another call
another call for skilled workers to come
to Alberta a similar ad campaign last
year appealed to the Etheridge family
they moved from Keswick Ontario to
Edmonton in search of a better life and
a much bigger backyard in Ontario we
rented a four-bedroom house we didn't
have a yard and we were paying 2600 plus
utilities whereas living in Alberta we
pay less than eighteen hundred dollars
for a five bedroom house like many young
families they felt priced out in Ontario
I couldn't have asked for a better
change to be honest it has been a whole
360 for our family completely
inter-provincial migration volumes
plunged in 2020 the first year of the
pandemic but they exploded last year
Alberta saw the biggest spike in
newcomers from BC and Ontario while the
Maritime Provinces welcomed a steady
stream of people mostly from Ontario
economists say it boils down to housing
options affordability and job prospects
that is driving a lot of young people to
move farther away from where they
started to set up shop to start a career
and to have a family the most expensive
Urban centers have seen in Exodus of
talent youth bring that entrepreneurship
that sense of innovation that ability to
create new businesses bring new ideas to
the business world and ultimately to
drive economic growth but housing
analysts say this unprecedented
inter-provincial migration may be
helpful as Canada prepares to welcome a
record number of newcomers from abroad
most new Canadians relocate in the
Golden Horseshoe in Southern Ontario so
if anything the out movement of people
to other regions of the country is
providing something of a above relief
valve it's it's helping keep a lid on
uncomfortably High home price
appreciation and gaviola Global News
Toronto
[Music]
still ahead what we know about a new
covid-19 subvariant as case counts creep
upwards
there's a new covid-19 sub-variant eg.5
it's a more infectious descendant of
Omicron and it's on the rise
it's estimated it already makes up 36
percent of all coveted 19 cases in
Canada
the new mutations being circulating in
this country since at least may as
Catherine Ward reports Health officials
are once again calling on everyone to
mask up and get their booster shot
today we will be classifying this as a
variant of Interest that's eg.5 a
covid-19 subvariant that's being
discovered around the globe it's
effectively a cousin of the Omicron
variant
say stronger variance and subvariants
are to be expected so that means that
this virus uh directly can spread more
uh faster faster and uh be more
pathogenic but virologists say the new
variant does not appear to make people
more sick epidemiologist Dr prabha says
there is no need to panic the risk seems
to be low but not zero uh certainly of
having something really catastrophic is
what has happened in the past because
we've built up hybrid immunity still
Public Health experts are keeping a
close eye on what covid and other
viruses are doing to prepare themselves
for the fall but what we will have as we
did last fall is call it a triedemic
we'll have covid circulating again we'll
have seasonal flu and will have RSV that
also causes people uh particularly the
elderly or the young to get sick experts
say getting a booster is one of the best
lines of Defense pediatric infectious
disease physician Dr Jesse papenberg is
hopeful they will be made available
available for even the youngest
Canadians currently in Canada there's
only the only products that are approved
for booster dose use are in children
five and above but we expect that by the
Fall Health Canada will approve also
products for those that are six months
of age and above until then experts say
washing your hands using masks and test
kits can go a long way we cannot predict
the future
but we can prepare for the future
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
[Music]
next the wide range of emotions among
swifties trying to get tickets to
Taylor's Toronto shows
did anybody get a code
and if you did get a cold please just
tell me that you didn't because if I
didn't and you did I'm just gonna it's
gonna ruin my whole life
safeties are stressing about Advanced
tickets for Taylor Swift's era's tour
coming to Toronto next year Ticketmaster
released codes to fans who registered in
advance but many Die Hard fans have now
been put on a waiting list
Brittany Rosen has spoken with some
lucky and some disappointed fans
Brittany
hi pharah from pre-teens to mothers with
children it seems like everybody across
the country is trying to get their hands
on these tickets because Toronto is the
only stop that Taylor Swift is making in
Canada on this tour and Canadians aren't
just competing with the rest of the
country but with Americans who weren't
able to snatch up tickets over there and
likely International fans as well and
even if you get this magic fan code
there are still no guarantees
forget Willy Wonka for Swifty's a golden
ticket means getting to see this
Superstar songstress for her heiress
tour next year to limit Bots resellers
and site crashes Ticketmaster release
codes to fans with staggered purchase
times I've won the lottery already just
with the code right so the icing on the
cape would be the ticket Dan physical
signed up as the verified fan and
received a code her opportunity to book
tickets is scheduled for Thursday
afternoon I whisper in the hallway she's
a bad bad girl 13 year old Naomi wamala
and her best friend Zoe Gibson are
die-hard t-swift fans but will not have
a chance to test their luck like many
they've been put on the waiting list I
ask like everyone I know to sign up but
no one got so like stressful to try and
get tickets because not everyone's going
to get them even like Americans are
trying to get tickets hashtag waitlisted
was trending on Twitter as swifties
shared in their frustration some of
those given a code and opportunity to
purchase tickets saw 300 section tickets
going for as low as 110 dollars while
resellers were already advertising them
for just under three thousand dollars
Ticketmaster did not respond to our
request for comment on average this year
swifties have spent more than Seventeen
hundred dollars not only on tickets but
also on accommodation and food and if
you didn't have that fan code well you
could be out of luck as there have not
been any announcements for general
public ticket sales and pharah even if
you try and get them on resale sites
well they're bound to go for sky-high
prices
thanks Brittany and that's global
national for this Wednesday night I'm
foreign Oster on behalf of our whole
crew I want to thank you for spending
part of your evening with us tonight's
your Canada is this Old Barn near
mankota Saskatchewan until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
[Music]
thank you